we're back we're
back we're back we're back we're back
we're back what's that it's the new we
we coming back in song welcome back to
Jim Norton and Sam
Roberts the trpes okay cool we can get
our guest in or no yeah waiting you were
waiting for what you could tell me to
bring him in all right that's usually
how it happens o no usually someone's
got a little very dismissive someone's
got a little sass for the boss yeah hey
boss you know how it goes I'm glad he
waits till the very last minute to set
the room up too I know well he's got to
stand around and just just gossip yeah
all right Taz what's going on good to
see you hello Taz you right there right
here in the seat of Honor yeah all right
Taz and I were texting about how it's
difficult to find producers that don't
you I won't be able to see you why I
want to sit the corner I no we like you
in the middle you belong in the middle I
want I I don't want have that
intimidation with you he want
cor what a strange egg all right hold on
Taz wants the corner he wants to be
trapped which mic is that five two two
he likes a nice confined space I just
want to cause problems right yeah to be
difficult you're being swaddled that's
being swaddled in way this is my M you
got an adapter for me he's just all
kinds of requests as soon as he gets
here a guest hey I'm not used to being a
guest what this freaking mic is I know
well you picked the wrong mic T we
wanted joh that one what do you need he
knows what I need he knows what I that's
right right now he's on his knees yeah
he knows what you
need he knows he knows get under the
table a right you know what he needs get
under the table right some sloppy white
time to join the [__] Squad Adrian that's
right that's right you're only a
Corporal dude that's why you want me
another mic the other mic's better so
what's up I appreciate you having
MEC definitely I qu some of your show
yesterday the the lith Lithgow
what liow yeah he was pretty hary guy
I'm not a Harve guy yeah I didn't know
he was either until we started doing
research on him I didn't realize he had
graduated from Harvard yeah he's a very
smart guy smart guy oh wait you use your
own headphones yeah I don't want to get
no are you a germ freak are you a germ
guy little bit yeah okay that's why you
don't use that mic CU that's the more
common mic correct so you want to use
the corner mic you think no by the way
that's the microphone that not that you
care but when homeless people come in
that is the mic they sit on Sam normally
sits on that one so you're actually on
the dirtier mic not don't mind I'm good
I I just because I'm not going to touch
it no I'm not that big of a germaphobe
but like working over the years in TV
and radio ears I just work I always have
my own stuff I don't blame you these
have my name on them these uh these have
yep they say [__] on them they're
that's how we know but yeah I I I'm the
same way I don't want weird people
touching my [__] just my ears you know
that's the thing cuz you can get
infection and [__] in your ears and it's
like if you're not you know guys that
are [__] jabronies that coming oh
yeah I'll put the headsets on I bring my
own [__] kep done doing my show so here
I am professional are you do you carry
purel yeah sometimes I'm not obsessed
Vince McMahon is uh like that that
that's bad though because what happens
is you start to kill healthy bacteria
and you get warts on your fingers yes
well yeah you could get definitely does
v man have warts on his fingers I don't
know I never looked at his fingers heon
Shake unless he's going like this pay me
then I I mean but I don't really know uh
yeah so I just got done doing my thing
and uh and I just we're block we're
black here like you I'm right on 50 what
is your show on CB um well it streams
video live video and audio every day and
Taz has an issue because people do not
understand the difference between a show
and a podcast he doesn't like cuz Taz is
on cbs's internet radio network that's a
dirty word what's what's the dirty word
streaming stream internet's dirty too
internet's filthy oh I know [__]
internet is f internet radio what am I
in [__] Fu College exactly what is he a
child with no career no yeah exact thank
you 30 [__] career [__] my body's
busted up and I'm on internet radio no
no you're on streaming radio I stream
live video my show is a live [__]
video show for the not here I'm getting
upset not at you guys because this to to
Sam's Point Jim this is a topic I'll let
you finish setting up that irks me a
little bit well yeah Sam is perpetuating
the myth of the show not being as good
as it is that Sam is perpetuating that
[__] stereotype so to Sam's Point
cuz here's the thing Jimmy you you I
know you're not a huge wrestling fan you
know a little bit but I know he's a
bigger fan so like in the wrestling
realm as he could tell you podcasting is
like this huge thing sure right so but
my show I used to be a podcast with CBS
a a weekly podcast was just like
everybody else like Sam does his podcast
the same way I would do mine now about
past almost two years uh CBS opened up
for me to do live video and audio
streaming every day Daily Show 7:00 a.m.
to 9:00 a.m. so I'm live video and audio
and it drops as a daily podcast drops
his VOD the whole show the whole 2 hours
so yeah but the problem is people are
like oh yeah I listen to taz's podcast
and he goes God damn it I do two hours a
day every day you guys just like you but
see the thing is like um I'm not on
terrestrial radio I'm not on broadcast
like you guys aren't either this is
satellite radio so satellite radio you
know satellite's obviously A Step Above
streaming or as Sall [__] internet
yeah right right put my mouth I just put
my mouth on this thing BR that's okay
believe me I said that on many
dates
there you go so that's the deal so yeah
no it's become a run and joke on my show
like fans call in and stuff and it's
like oh the podcast it's like we don't
we call it the p word yeah it's just
very sophomore but you know what even
the the only good thing about calling it
the podcast is people understand the
availability and how to grab a podcast
there is one good thing about the
podcast label people know you can go to
iTunes and get it or go here and just
grab it and download it so it's
available there are younger people that
when you're like no I do a talk show I
do a talk show on the radio they're like
what the [__] you talking
how do you hear that I understand I know
it's it gets FR like with my show it's
really easy I mean CBS I got to say they
set it up a pretty good way you just go
to one website if you want to watch it
live or listen it live or the podcast is
like I'm sure like your show iTunes
Spotify whole tune in all that St well
you actually you and um help me do an
MMA podcast s mat s think him and I
don't live that far from each other we
never met oh really I know a lot of his
do I live on the island and I know I
live in Nassau County without getting
into details CU I think him and I live
off air we talk but okay I think we
actually some people told me that we
actually live a lot closer to each other
I never met him oh he's a great guy yeah
I heard heard he's a good guy I know I
drive by a lot of his schools I heard
he's a good dude so uh yeah he brought
his daughters onto the podcast his wife
they went to see The Lion King so his
wife and daughters came in he's a lovely
family he like a nice nice guy beat the
[__] out Savage guy I know he's a beast
I know he's but his kids are adorable
and he's just like a doting emotional
Dad yeah loves his kids how old are his
kids I want to say 128 and six or 10 in
that area I don't know I only met them
once is he getting the 12-year-old into
Athletics yet or he I think they dance I
think they have like little uh like
little yeah I think they do like uh
ballet or something no if they're girls
that's cool oh yeah three three three
daughters I don't maybe I don't I don't
say someone's got a boy that don't don't
disrespect nobody [__] has a bull boy
that dances oh let's be honest they're
all daughters I'm just saying like it's
not no disrespect for a boy [__] out of
here I got a son who's 17 years old he
High School senior and he's a lacrosse
player and he's going to play in college
next year D1 and and so I he doesn't
dance no he doesn't dance he will beat
the piss out of you with a stick in his
hand a metal six foot ble yeah I'll tell
you this though maybe if he was a
football player like Lyn Swan took
ballet cuz it does help a lot of times
when you're going up for uh that's going
for a pass they call a pass Jimmy pass I
put my
arms but you couldn't see as I pushed my
hips out I was I was still in the ballet
mode you were actually dancing slightly
it was a little bit of a dance familiar
with with uh with his ballet work than
his football work but mat Matt's
daughters are are I think they are take
ballet or some sort of actually it's an
underrated that's that's a art in itself
you got to be athletic and and Nimble
and uh and uh Supple as they call it
that's a word you might want to Google
you him not you him not you him they
must get pissed off though because I
feel like any time anybody gets an
injury in a sport the first thing
somebody goes is well it's not ballet
that's true that's actually very good
point said that a billion times on
wrestling broadcast well [__] it's not
ballet guy P his out it's not ballet so
that means I'm going break it down for
you Jim so that means basic look you see
no no I think I know what he means so
don't talk down to me Taz when I walk
out he will he's going to rip me no I
won't cuz you can still walk back
in dude you and I Jimmy haven't seen
each other in ages man I know I mean way
back you know the first time we did
radio together I want to say it was on
the old opian Anthony show probably
around
20012 you're right bro yeah it was a
long time ago very long time ago always
were a good dude even though people talk
[__] about you and rip you I always
you're a good guy thank you very much I
appreciate it he's right they would
humiliate and emasculate me he would
always be there yeah actually it's funny
cuz I threw him a follow about a week
ago on the Twitter nothing back I didn't
know I haven't check I literally have
not checked my app mentions in three
weeks I'm verified bro you would get a
notification I will check those I'm
[__] I mean Jimmy I'm waiting I've
been sitting around waiting for this I
didn't even check I I'll I'll check it
don't follow me but I'll check it no
actually I'm going to block you now
that's F because I'm pissed this stuff
personally
day Tex follow me back yet hypers
sensitive people think I am that's why I
keep rolling with it oh okay like on my
show you know when you call the show as
a guest I mean as a fan you never know
what's going to happen you know cuz I
could get a little like I embrace I love
my audience just like you guys right but
sometimes I will get a little
confrontational like if you say
something stupid like everybody's I I'm
I'm lucky I got an awesome audience you
know they that that's kind of like built
I built that Niche just like any you
know just like you guys and you know but
sometimes people get a little what I
call comfy Jones they get a little
comfortable you know you know what I
mean they get a little comfortable then
you got to [__] shoot them down and
people that you know or on the phones no
just people I don't know anyone I avoid
everybody I just stay to myself so
people on the phones like people on on
the social media and I'm very active on
the social media if you looked at your
[__] Twitter account you would know
I'm pretty active if you follow him but
you don't follow him so you wouldn't
know I know that was a stupid
question
sometimes no no sometimes the only
stupid question is the question you
don't know the answer to and the fact
that I I knew the answer to that but I
said let Taz tell the audience but how
can I get him to tell the audience I'll
ask the question as if many of them
Jimmy just joking around he's getting
old deep the only stupid question is one
you don't know the answer to what's
wrong with you why [__] why do you have
me come to something like this where I'm
getting attacked and flogged no you're
right it is is an expression Sam you
just haven't
heard you know we have a we also have a
good
subsidary douche we douche we also have
a good listener base but they remember
like they know their place in the
pecking order cuz we call our listeners
uh the come
Squad Jim Jim and I are the cap co-
captains of the [__] Squad that's right
and the big saying is drink up actually
co- captains is pretty funny yeah I
don't you know I I respect because you
guys I you guys don't do a uh I'm big
into what we call the sound effect St
like it's it's been done in radio a
billion times 360 you know what I mean
sure and I it's a big part of my show
and I have and so I'm so used to when I
have a mic and doing a show I'm used to
hitting buttons cuz I do it myself Jim's
got buttons all I certainly do but you
got I certainly do I remember
masturbating oh wow you have a bro you
have a a
fancy masturbating see that's a that's a
very uh fancy bro it sure is yeah yeah
all the side though I have the one I
have the one this is no [__] this is
what CBS told me they could be lying
right I have the one that they could be
lying that Stern used oh you're not so
smart now see now i i s him up now sorry
I don't mean it he gets distracted he
look I'm joking guys are right all right
go ahead sorry about that he shouldn't
have the buttons no I actually like that
he has the buttons cuz he's I can't help
it people think it's so we dude you're
so [__] you're a funny guy you don't
even need it I need it cuz I'm not funny
no but I enjoy them I I have a good hey
whoa hey hey hey you're a crumb creep
all right all sorry we're all good now
too much he puts his own voice on the my
voice on my show oh boy yeah You're
Gonna Come hey you're gonna come on my
show right you're g walk Street and come
on my show be delighted and you should
come on UFC unfiltered I would love to
I'm sure you and Matt would get along
Matt a very fun guy I heard he is and I
think we have a couple mutual friends I
would but I'm serious both you guys one
day cuz we're right across the street
you got to come on you're on live at 8
right 8 to 11 yeah yeah you get up a
little early come on I'm live at 7 you
come up we actually could do that you do
that and you know I've never invited Sam
on unfilter of course you'd be welcome
to come on I come on anytime
seem I'm just saying like you you guys
work you like all a sudden you [__]
inviting him the guy in the Patagonia
Hat's laughing too he got is that a
Patagonia hat that's Patagonia oh
[__] guy Sam you're actually
impressed I know patagon I was impressed
it's not good my manager my old agent
Pete who's one of my favorite people my
manager Jonathan is a [__] not a good
name at all good man terrible name anywh
patagon is and Jonathan always found
that repulsive he patagon yeah he hated
I think vigan Vines is more of a kind of
a [__] thing uh where Patagonia I
think's a little bit more hog I got some
Patagonia stuff it's all like it's all
bro culture right like adrianne's like
the biggest bro that I know I have a kid
who dresses like him so is he a bro he
plays lacrosse he's a lacrosse player
yeah yeah yeah right yeah 17y lacrosse
Play One lacrosse player going to
college and you know his name I
don't tell me name I thought you were
Adrian oh oh Adrian don't you come in
my
dude you're not really good with the
gimmick I'm not just getting there did
you I'm going to come
button why' you I didn't mean to why did
you click that it was a mistake I hit
the wrong button yeah this is why no
okay the side this is why the instant
replays better because it's it's
all buttons T tell you bro I asked for
that originally the old Replay that
Anthony had and uh I kind of wanted one
of those but this is what they brought
me and I I believe me I've complained
about it my finger hits it sometimes I'm
zipping around boom doing this and I hit
buttons you would hate it dude they they
would they had to give Jim an
instructional course it's a it's a touch
not a tap it's a press press it's a it's
a press it's a press not a touch or a
tap if you touch or you tap no no that's
the ships that's the ships and I'll tell
you why cuz when you're doing a show
it's got you guys done enough boom boom
right got be quick in and out quick boom
although sometimes the old replay
wouldn't work either but I agree because
I have to actually look and hit it and
go oh okay Adrian I've never heard that
name on a man before but see that's
actually a good drop yeah I like I like
the thing where you said you were going
to come over his name better I do too ad
yeah that
was yeah that
waset yeah but no you guys got to walk
over there one day you [__] do it's a
block away right bro 50 and how many
times I got to tell you 50 and come on I
want to make sure I get it right I have
seven concussions do you really yeah do
you have any CTE problems or no I think
so do you honestly but it's part of the
game do you get like things I have
shortterm memory yeah I I I have that
too but not from conc do you get do you
get uh like rage thing like like Tony
Dorth from the Cowboys was talking about
his I know fits of Rage H it could
happen not as often as some guys that I
actually know um I I not really fits of
Rage I'll I'll lose my back in the day
to my Prime I really wasn't that
short-tempered people thought I was
because of my character that I portrayed
um I was an intense guy and took
everything all business but I did not
have a short temper as I get older now
believe it or not my temper is a little
uh you know I guess cuz I got a
17-year-old he makes me crazy sometimes
you know but he's a good kid I'm blessed
my wife and I very lucky to have you're
more irritable now a little bit a little
bit because I'm just I get uh I'm I'm
the type of guy that just I want to win
you know like I always want to I always
try to be better seriously everything I
do every show anything I do in my life
my wife and I raised my kid that way
thank God he's doing good thing is so
I'm always I'm never good enough so I
get tense sometimes and I and I I I kind
of I guess have a little F of Rage
was your was I got problems why why why
you feel compe was you like was your
parents like that like they wanted you
to be a certain D my dad was competitive
guy but I grew up just as an athlete
know I was a football player I played
Judo I was you know very involved with
anything physical very type A alwayss
and then being in the wrestling business
being 5 foot nothing and being in a Land
of giants you know I built a [__]
chip on my shoulder the size of Texas
you know what I'm saying so now as I'm
older you know I'm I'm getting a little
better with that I don't I'm actually
all can as side I'm the happiest I've
ever been professionally like in my
career like what I do for a living doing
this doing radio and and internet radio
as some people call it some people call
internet radio I call it streaming media
yeah streaming media media wow see right
now I would hit on a 360 I have
a I have an all you don't have it no I
have this it's
better thank that kind of fits that's
for the internet radio dude I got to
tell you the 360 blows that away I'm
just I I know believe me it was what I
asked I'm obsessed with this let me ask
you so so uh you you you would get this
this competitive thing and and you uh
you took Judo did you compete in Judo
yeah I did but just local stuff and but
football was my thing I thought I was
going to be I was a good player were you
lineman I was a I was a nose God I
played linebacker too so I played both
but the thing was and then you know
being 5 foot 5'8 5'9 you know it's kind
of tough to excel I grew up in a city I
went to school in Brooklyn so you know
back in the day there weren't many guys
going to play D1 college football out of
Brooklyn a 5'8 you know what I mean it
didn't happen and but in my brain I was
going and it didn't happen how much did
you weigh though did you weigh enough to
compete against those guys no I was
probably about in high school my senior
year I probably weigh about 225 so wow I
wasn't a little I was a solid big
bencher I was in high school I was
benching like probably uh probably 315
for two reps I was a strong kid I was
always a big weight room kid you know
what I mean always uh so and that that
helped me and competing but going to
college and playing football I love
doing that but I didn't like going to
class so that didn't last I kind of had
leave so and then I got into wrestling
you just stick around want just hang out
I always wonder about that like super
competitive people in the wrestling
world where it's like you're not
responsible for your wins and losses and
if that means something to you like like
you know guys that come from like MMA or
Olympic wrestling or whatever when they
come into professional wrestling and
they just have to wrap their heads
around the fact that the performance is
not based on your win loss record right
so is that difficult for somebody who's
competitive like you uh
uh well the amount of money you make to
I gu to your point and it's just true
the amount of money you make and the
high you earn a card is not contingent
on how good you are believe it or not
because once you get to that level of
WWE or working with one of the main
companies you're kind of everybody's
good in the ring you know everybody's
for the most part are good workers you
just don't get to that point so that
part's done so now what's contingent is
the way you are politically behind the
scenes if you're kissing ass that's not
good cuz then the talent the locker room
hates you and the office can tell when
you're an ass kisser but if you're too
much of a hard ass that doesn't help
either because then like the Locker
Room's like this guy's a douche and the
office doesn't want to deal with you so
you got to kind of that that middle
ground for me that was I wasn't good at
that okay that was a kind of like were
you the ass kisser no no I was all
business you know I mean even in ECW
throughout my success and Haymon gave me
so many opportunities Paul and I had a
very strain relationship I know you know
Paul so you ask him one day I mean like
I'm him and I but we love each other
don't get me wrong I mean I I respect
the he fight a lot oh back in the day
during ECW God him and I would fight all
the time but I always had that respect
for him because he was the boss you know
and I he was a lot smarter than me so
you know have you had to fight with
program directors in radio uh that a
little bit yeah I heard that's the
shifts yeah but I I just wouldn't want
to fight with t like it's one thing if
you're a wrestling promoter that's used
to dealing with people like but for like
a weener you know program director to
have to deal with this funny enough to
your point like I was uh when I first
started with CBS so where I do my show
I'm on the CBS Radio corporate floor so
I'm not at WFA like I'm not downtown you
know what I mean so I'm around like all
these corporate people and here I am
doing my show they they converted like
an office I was like a guinea pig into
this gimmick Clubhouse we call it where
I do my show it's like a memorabilia on
the wall it's kind of a cool feel right
and uh like a CA a man cave type feel
and here I am streaming and screaming
doing my [__] going nuts for two hours
and I'll walk out to you know take a
leak during a break and it's like people
walking around in suits and all quiet
it's different here it's just he's a
full-blown Studios I mean you have
corporate people here I'm sure on the
floor and and upstairs most of them
upstairs so see where I am they put me
right in the middle of all these people
but there's at least don't Jael well
with them right and there's some kind of
acknowledgement here that like when you
go to the bathroom like people know that
you're doing a radio show and there's
this thing whereas it sounds like over
there it's like what's that guy doing
here dude in the summer I'm walking
around I got shorts on flip-flops you
know tank top tattoos go to the bathroom
people walk around in suits they W even
make eye contact see doesn't that make
they don't even look at me don't that
make you feel good that makes me feel
very good because you're in this thing
and we're doing what we want to do and I
see guys that have to wear a suit to
work and I'm like oh my God am I glad
that's not me that's for the grace of
God Jim for the Mak makes you grateful
for because you're doing something fun
it it is sitting there in a [__]
cubicle and you guys are doing this a
lot lower than me you know individual
stuff you've done and now together you
guys are teaming up this is newer right
with you two guys we our our show this
show began in October cool and uh
congrats thank you man yeah seriously I
mean that I mean it's hard I don't think
people realize how hard it is to even
two cats like you involve in radio for
so long and you involved with comedy for
as many years but it's still hard to get
a show like to get that opportunity and
no matter what company you worked for
what you do and stuff like it's it's
[__] hard you got to be a shark yeah
well you never take it for granted I
mean like the the bottom I never think
that this gig can't go away right right
right so I'm happy is here well you've
been fired a lot I'm sure in your life
you know what not really we got we got L
we got fired that one time assuming I
know I'm just assuming Jimmy I just yeah
no in the last show we had a parting of
the ways Mutual I heard yeah yeah that
wasn't a firing you either neither of us
got fir right everybody's still here
yeah we're all still here everything's
getting awkward now not at all I feel
wonderful me and my little twink partner
are having a good time that's me yeah
got know little Squad is in the house
co-
Captain spankable twink you yeah who who
you pointing at Aid patagon he pointing
at me a why you poin at teag to Mark the
[__] Squad stuff oh cuz I said [__] Squad
in the house see he's he's pointing it
at dbag I like the nickname dbag yeah
well if fits him remember that
conversation we had over txt about how
difficult it is to find a good producer
amen so like I uh we're on break right
yeah and we're coming back and dag has
just been standing in here taking up
space the entire time he wasn't doing
anything he was just kind of lumping
around with his [__] shitty stack bro
he left me the guest former world
champion like a [__] schmuck in the
hallway wait till you hear this so the
music's playing we're coming back and
he's just kind of slowly turning the
cameras on slow I go like this are you
going to get our guest right before the
mics come on and he gives me this look
like how dare you and he goes well I was
going to wait until you ask me like
usual what the f and he walks out where
he's left the human suplex machine just
standing by himself Derek comment on
this shitty attitude you're suddenly giv
the boss what you got another
opportunity somewhere CNN Colin he's
going to
CBS I see him on the T show yeah my new
producer dag welcome to the show hey hey
stash hey stash uh yeah I see got the
little yeah yeah no usually I wait until
you guys come back from break and then
you banter for 30 seconds and you say
okay let's bring our guest in so that's
we always bring and we always leave
guest sitting at that same chair in the
hallway this was no ex okay yeah I know
now now he's saying look Taz you're not
offer and got you a cup of coffee and I
thank you and I [__] thank you bro
bro did I not bro did I not thank you
did I not thank you you did I'm just
saying it was okay you want [__] $2
for the coffee what do you want please
don't bust my balls what do you mean
didn't and what do you mean did did I
not that's part of your job is to make
our guest comfortable that didn't I turn
on your microphone care it's my
job good point dag I'm a little
disappointed in you I don't even know
you I'm just telling you that right now
a little disappoint there's an
implication that I was discourteous to
by you were a little disc courious sir
because you had be [__] standing
there you shouldn't do that on my show
you would last a day you'd be gone as a
producer you're lucky these guys are
nice and he even said and in a little
attitude to Sam well that's how it
usually works yeah I know like but
that's the thing that's why you know you
got to [__] be careful with these
people that you get around you I no my
man with the patagon hat I can see he's
legit adri I tell Adrian Adrian I can
tell never heard that name on a man
before yeah that's good [__] Adrian
consider that stolen I'm gonna get that
Dr I actually like that that's probably
Deb good talking to you [__] hates
that guy hates me right now he does well
he doesn't like he does not
like exactly what's he going to do about
go on Twitter and bury me why you give
me a troll are you going to troll me
[__] what are you going to do about it
what you going to do DB you yeah what
are you going to do what are you going
to do py what are you going to do listen
bro this is Radio you can't be thin
skinned yeah what you going to cry speak
I'm crying good what you going do what
are you going to do be you you cannot
take yourself serious sir you cannot do
that dag yeah he probably's pissed that
he has the name dag too he's pissed
about it but for those that don't know
is short F douchebag that's right now I
don't know if the kid's a douchebag or
not but I know he left me the hall like
a schmuck what's your first impression
if you had to guess I met him in a
wholeway he was a nice kid he said hello
he introduce first he looked around he
had no idea where I was which was fine
no problem I you know I haven't been in
my Prime in a long time but I mean I
know I'm just a washed up wrestler you
know so so you know so I could see that
that he didn't recognize me which is
okay I'm not need it though Seth Rollins
the face look at the face on dag I'm
gonna tweet that
out Dag's face as Taz is giving him a
beating oh is he none too pleased bro
yeah he looks mad deag I gotta walk when
I walk out of he might come at me oh
he's not happy just sign a release and
we're good and then we'll do whatever we
got to do you know what I mean young I'm
going to Tweet this right now I took a
quick photo a little uh we videotape
everything in here but young Derek is
not on uh Twitter right oh my God he
looks just who is that guy he looks just
like he's a Mississippi State fan it
looks like on the Twitter so who
Stingray Steve I've shown him to you
before he's the Mississippi State Super
Fan who graduated from Alabama is that
right he graduated from Alabama this is
Mississippi yeah dag listen bro we got
off to the wrong foot here thank you for
the coffee no problem it's my job a boy
disingenuous Jones right there right
very dis that's okay we're good Deb
we're good it was very nice of you Deb
it was you're very you're very very nice
now put that sword away all right hold
on I'm just I'm tweeting this out
struggle with the Twitter no no I'm I'm
uh in the te box I'm I'm saying where he
is that's right okay and do you he
doesn't even know I have a Twitter Jim
don't yes I he forgot that you followed
him yeah I'm blocking him bro I swear
I'm not kidding you I'm definitely
blocking your official Taz on Twitter oh
that'd be me sir yes uh yeah gives him a
beating it was good
voice oh my God it's hot in here bro
what's going on with the heat well
that's deag again [__] us over every
time yeah it is really hot here he turns
it up because he wants our guest to be
uncomfortable yeah he said that before
there's also a chair there I
mean I maybe I don't feel like sitting
in a chair sir you're getting all worked
up this is what I do maybe I don't feel
like sitting in a May doesn't feel like
uh you know what you know what hey dbck
you know what maybe my body is so [__]
up that my back and my I have nerve
damage on the right side of my body
that's sitting down I don't have the
sell to
you answer the question hit the button
son hit the butt 25 he talked he talked
into an off microphone 25 fool you're 25
you're a young kid you can sit down and
chance I got a [__] up hit I got a sad
what do you call it nerve what do you
call it sciatic ner got the I got
numbness in my [__] hand I got this
kid telling me to sit down bro I'm not
sitting down see I didn't want to come
in here and get work I want to do this
how old were you when you won your first
uhcw TV Championship she can we GTS that
that's Google can someone Google that I
don't know I think I wanted um sting RAC
how old was I Manish yeah yeah probably
96 then vanam beat me for and held it
for like 6,000 years years Rob had it
forever but how old do you think you
were uh I was probably maybe 28 28 you
got three years to win a championship
Absolutely I'll start now absolutely
what are you doing he was holding gold
by the time he was 28 you get it let me
know if you got it I don't I know you're
looking for it I can't he wrestling with
that mustache losing what's that dude
the tag Championship no uh television
championship in uh ECW uh March 94 so
I'm 49 now let's do the math cuz I'm not
good at it help me oh the Tas Maniac won
the title three years ago that you were
26 I was 26 I was a year older than you
dbag and I wanted to and he had the gold
he already had gold the champion of
television what are you winning that's
right I like that nothing yeah that's
right that's right I mention thank you
for the call for yeah you are a champion
of exactly I will never next time I come
because I'm coming back you are it's an
open invite
yesd ref won't work next time I come
back I do not only want I don't want
coffee from bag I don't even want to
interact with him I don't play I want to
I want to do an air high five with him
from here what up [__] out you bro
that's it I don't want to to get you
from the back though who's going to
bring you back no you're going to get me
a pass I'm coming right in right okay
Adrian you take care of T
adri name on a man
before trying to impress t i I love it
it is impress me it's growing on me
thing is bro I was here years ago I told
you this Sam and like texting dude I me
I was doing show here when Stern first
came over like they were looking for
programming there this might be awkward
for you guys oh wow the air kicked in
the air condition beautiful there it is
thank you Adrian thanks adri I've never
heard that name on a man I know so it's
a very close dealing hey hey hey don't
interrupt me
[__] that's
good we get you that button too oh I
know I love that oh so you wanted to do
a show when when Howard was doing me and
Michael Cole who's the the play-by-play
man for raw yeah uh he and I were
working on Smackdown we would call a
comment the announce team so we were
doing shows here like demo shows not
like wrestling shows just shows no yeah
guy talk stuff around 2006 2007 whenever
Scott Greenstein first came into the
fold like right before that cuz we
weren't here at that point we were on XM
only I think at that point correct I
think you're right and what happened was
this will help you with the timeline I
come in with Michael Cole we did a bunch
of shows they seemed like they loved
everything everything was cool and um we
thought like we were going to come to
terms and then Tim Sabian at the time
was the PD for stern steal I only met
him a couple times I saw there was some
faces made here I don't know the guy
like you guys would know he ran our
channel for a little while is the
problem he was a big Jim Norton guy yeah
he was trying to get rid of me get me
off the show and he wound up no no no
please then he now he's gone I apologize
he said he wasn't trying to get rid of
me but he was you think so I always know
yeah always you can always figure it out
always good I respect that J always I
know brother I know what you mean
regardless so that brick no no Tim
savkin so he was uh he was here and then
what's his name uh Scott farell ended up
getting the gimmick instead of me and
Michael he had a lot of experience in
radio you know now he's CBS now I
remember when Scott was going for that
we were fighting with him at the time
even though we like f was stupid yeah um
but yeah I think he's uh he did get the
gig on
serus
like a nighttime show I don't remember
the day part but it was maybe 9900 p.m.
whatever heck it was now I know he's at
he's at CVS Sports though I know that I
mean yeah everybody's got thrown off
Howard's Channel since then so you're
they really did right even Stingray
deag why would guys getting thrown off
he doesn't have like the channel they
didn't they first they flushed out the
channels with a whole bunch of shows and
then they decid they took them all off
and now because they just want more
Howard stuff on oh okay so you might be
better off for it yeah I guess I would
have been fired yeah exactly Cole and I
would have quit Smackdown to get fired
two years later right oh wow good move I
guess things happen for a reason and now
you're you're you're part of streaming
media yes dude I got to hire you as like
you got like a publicity agent you got
the terminology down it's all in the way
you sell it right streaming media I've
never used and now I have to use that
cuz I'm doing a pleth I'm doing video
I'm doing audio I don't want to brag but
let's be honest I'm doing it all here
you got a whole bunch of uh stuff you
whole bunch of uh irons in the fire yeah
it's a cliche but yeah yeah bunch of
hooks in the water yeah when are you
when are you uh doing some stand up on
the island again it'll be a while I did
one gig on Long Island during the tour
but but then when I when I started
touring again where where was that uh
the Paramount it was great really really
nice place awesome yeah it's really nice
there yeah I should have done two shows
there I just did one yeah yeah yeah says
I know want to what's that place uh mes
not M and there's the other The Comedy
Club there that's real PO broid is great
brok yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you guys
been uh have you guys been cover and the
catch me outside girl on your show oh my
God another problem with this poor girl
this is the girl from with Dr Phil we
covered it a little bit not not much at
all catch me outside yeah catch catch me
outside how about it how about it so
you're like kind of obsessed with this
thing I are you trying to get her on a
show trying to date her well she's 13
youed five years ago he was trying to
date her trying to get her on a show I
mean you know it's get on a show we
would but like there all kinds of
stories so first she did Dr Phil again
after the first one yeah and she
informed Dr Phil she had like a little
bit of a deag Vibe about her to tell you
the truth she did she would do anything
she went on Dr Phil's show and told Dr
Phil that he needs to thank her yeah for
the amount of of Fame that's right
listen I got to tell you something Sam
tell me okay I think a lot of these
things like the Oscars the big [__] up
at the Oscars with the whole [__]
Warren Batty's 150 years old let's have
him open the [__] card thing right
all of this [__] I think is what we call
in my industry as you know a work okay I
do think I think here's the problem with
me I think everything's work the NFL NBA
everything's fake everything whenever
you can bet or gamble on something it's
there it's an inside game and it's fixed
and I've done this I've explained
different things even in MMA which
pissed off a lot of people not not all
of MMA but like I had a whole big thing
about Holly Hol and uh um Ronda Rousey I
thought some of that was a little uh
worked a little bit uh look at Jimmy I
can tell you why because there'd be no
advantage to it because the UFC lost so
much money with not being I hear you but
here's the thing I don't want to get
into this again but if you I I really
don't cuz this is like a whole big all
I'm going to say is to have something to
be a work you don't need both people
involved that's true you don't you you
don't but let's get back to the the
chick that you could throw a game one
team without doubt without a doubt so I
think like stuff like that with the Dr
Phil girl and all that that type of
stuff I think some of that stuff's it's
she's creating a brand now yes she's
creating a c now I'm going to give a
gift to the Jim Norton and Sam Roberts
show oh fabulous oh cool not a physical
gift it's cash it's not cash even just
broke D NE
I bro I do internet radio how can I give
cash as a GI I thought streaming media
paid well it does so so I'm G to I'm
going to give a suggestion okay I really
hope you guys don't have this because I
look like a [__] idiot okay you ought
to get that drop from that girl saying
that and that should be in that [__]
iPad right cash me outside yeah okay we
don't have it in there I told D to get
it and I told Adrian and no one got it
no you didn't tell Adrian did you really
my my mistake look at
when I said it a was like oh [__] T shut
up shut up so you okay so that's what
I'm saying that should be in there I
mean that's right but so now this chick
is uh she's charging 30,000 I'm sensing
there's a little lying going on here I
saw a look from Adrian Jim just made
that up I think just now I think he did
I think he did too and he's got such a
good poker face thank you oh well do
well how about this here we
go Merry
Christmas totally
random it's February almost March
exactly
we'll put that one on the back burner
plus he could just say that it's his
voice I Tred to give a gift to you guys
and then he tries to take cash me
outside is not bad though that would be
F you're going to use it once I'm gone
Adrian's going to get it you'll use that
[__] every day I guarantee be S I will
annoy everyone with that and I will get
no credit for it no you won't now if I
use it on my show right you stole it
from us but I won't hack I'm not a hack
so I'll give credit to us to you guys
even though you gave us the idea but
that's you right cuz you gave me the
idea of this cuz I think that way right
now Jimmy I'm losing him cuz he could
give a [__] fart right now and part of
me has to piss okay well get the cameras
on this could be simple minded guy me
have to make me have to make but they
catch me catch me out Z that whole thing
is a great bite it's a great bite Taz
goes like because the way I think I came
up with it in here and I was bouncing
off you guys that's how I think and Jim
just goes I have to fart and a little
bit same time he saw me leaning on one I
wasn't paying attention I TR catch like
this we saw catch a p trying to break
wind so so but anyway so now this girl
right and this actually goes to your
this guy OBS Sam is obsessed with I
heard you yesterday talk you really like
you need to talk about this yeah I want
to talk about it okay good go s a piece
of
garbage go ahead Sammy $30,000 for Club
appearances now are you rib the [__] she
too young for clubs
she $30,000 for Club appearances she
have a manager or an agent no but like
oh wa I'm sure she does I'm sure she got
just say she's building a brand I could
have sworn somebody said that it was
someone said that you said it me no oh
you
did she's 40,000 plus 40,000 plus yeah
yeah so that's why before like you know
we'd like to get her on the show but
she'd probably charge us money she's
yeah she you guys Grand she's going to
think you guys a Bonita to get her on
the show and now she's uh for she was in
a fight uh yesterday every time she goes
to another town okay wait do you think
tell me this Taz so she does these Club
appearances right yeah every time she
goes to another town There's a TMZ video
of her getting into a fight with
somebody Dam Skippy it's a work the
[__] cameras in there to catch the
work it's a screams work is this like
[__] her like building up her thing
so that people will keep paying to see
her in a club cuz she might get in a
fight is that BR she's getting 40
[__] lodge to do an appearance right
that show she's building a brand that
her publicist whoever is hooked up with
TMZ to get them there she gets to do a
[__] work fight with somebody boom
she gets more controversy yeah they get
on the holy [__] I got to explain
everything everywhere I go to people and
how much of this is the mother huh her
mother the mother the the mother yeah
the mother I like that the mother mother
she's involved with it yeah does she
have a father she I don't know about the
yes he's a cop in he's a cop in uh what
state is it Florida is Florida yeah he
hasn't made any any appearances it's
good parenting but like the mother don't
they live together or not though
shocking the Mother was complaining
about her on Dr Phil but then she's been
with her at every appearance the mother
helped her get into that fight on the
airplane this is the new one yeah
wearing fur coats saw sheor she doesn't
actually throw sry Jim I was talking
what oh sorry here I'll do it for you
don't interrupt me cun that's
right what so is she the the girl right
there who just picked something up you
guys want to hear it
yeah that's
annoying
[Applause]
[__] she wearing a grill she looks like
she be might be on some alcohol
something
marijuana she's too young for that what
what what am I looking at they're doing
nothing there's no fighting they
instigate a fight oh fight's coming yeah
they started the fight they don't I
don't think they
actually that goes to taz's conversation
between and her part went down do they
do stuff to what the [__] is that sound
what is going on here they're
instigating a fight yeah that means that
like you said it doesn't have to be two
people involved in the work they just
start the fight the other person that's
fighting with him doesn't have to be
involved I yes I would I would love to
break down this I wish Matt SAR was here
we could break this down
together but he's not so uh is there
actual Matt wouldn't break down this
fight though so I'm not gonna because he
he then I'm not gonna what my [__]
beneath Matt I like the guy I heard good
things now I'm a slun no but but he
wouldn't he would he would probably good
bad parenting and he'd be right that's
what I said yeah you're right you're
both right yeah you're know you're not
you're not been Matt Sarah you're damn
right you guys are say I never even met
him I want to meet the guy I think we
would get a long G you would Matt's a
very funny I'm not I'm actually not not
going to break this down actually I
don't want to see this I don't want this
part of my appearance on the Jim Norton
and Sam edit it out we're Tak out TR to
take this out of post and we don't call
it a podcast it's audio on demand yes it
is right audio on demand thank you sir
yes yeah this shirt doesn't even podcast
how about that oh yeah we do have a
podcast how about
that first of all she you're emphasizing
all the words she doesn't emphasiz she
goes how about that how about that where
where is where is this where's this kid
from where's she from Florida Florida oh
shock so much [__] goes on in Florida
bro you see people just get like it's
crazy what happens in Florida bro you
got to be a little [__] up I mean no
disrespect nobody lives in Florida but
you got to be a little [__] up to live
over there let's be honest iot where
people can hear your show Taz they can
hear it uh even in Flor CBS radio's
play.it online Network and um how how
it's official Taz on Twitter Taz
show.com so where exactly is is it
play.it online can you please let play
that it come on bro you know and he's on
you can watch the video you can listen
to it and then it's on there it is J
Jimmy look last night the T show I was
watching last night that was funny last
night I was watching [__] yeah that was
a good
one I thought it was funny when he said
it was funny he makes me laugh I'm sorry
I'm good last night I was watching the
end of the Taz Show from yesterday where
he said he was coming on the show and he
said I that I was not I was the least
controversial person that's what I said
ever I did say that about you're
non-confrontational non-confrontational
he's right ever he is that's good and
Jimmy a little bit I know of you you
seem non-confrontational at times I I
know you could be combustible I try to
be malleable yeah I don't know what that
means but okay you see us get Nancy
Grace to walk out of here I did actually
that was but but you guys were on fire I
did see that she was pissed but I
thought it was good yeah she was she was
incorrect sure she was and you kind of
let her know that yeah I saw that I stay
on top of everything but to help you
with that horrendous plug you gave my
show Jim um is written on the sheet yeah
that's called read copy I understand
Yeah so basically human suplex machine
you [__] no no I understand but I'm
trying to read it properly and it's not
my fault sheet was made up it is made
wrong whoever made this probably dbag um
it was it was dbag right it was dbag
Derek why is this written up like this
guy's got something in for me tell us
without throwing anybody else under the
bus no he's not completely wrong I got
to be
honest about this own this deag I I
[__] it up on
purpose I had malicious intent yes well
no this is what he has and Dag's got the
right info it's just I think Jimmy's
wrong here Jimmy read this wrong I
believe it was J it's Jimmy's fa
basically promoting the Taz Show
weekdays from 7:00 a.m. to 9:00 a.m. on
CBS Radio play.it online Network that's
where it's wrong so you can't listen or
watch my show on play.it no you can go
to Taz show.com which dbig has on here
and watch it live or listen to it live
right that you can do uh play that Jimmy
please but I didn't read it wrong you
did no I didn't no you didn't read it
wrong you're right you you got
information that was incorrect dbag so
that's why Jim is the captain of the
come Squad that's right all
all uh in and uh as far as uh dag he
he's not completely wrong because play.
it I don't think Dave what that is is
the
podcast why is that what what did he say
why
he on the radio just talking he [__]
he's got the key open bro I said should
I talk a little [__] yeah talk a little
[__] let me hear him asking Travis that
question can we hear that should I talk
a little [__] do you have
that no idea the m no the key was open
sh [__] yeah yeah let's see how you work
out CH doesn't know anything about doing
that yeah let's let's Jim you think I
should talk a little CH let's hear [__]
you think I should you think I should
nail him I'm a little surprised we have
the audio oh yeah Travis will get it
doesn't mind pulling it should I talk a
little set in the metime why Travis is
looking should I talk a little set I
can't wait to hear [__] that was
awful so rude and wrong and bad I don't
mind you being rude just be good at yeah
me sounds like one of the women from the
housewives of Minnesota stinks you want
to hear yes we
do as far as uh dag he he's not
completely wrong because play. it I
don't think Dave with that is is the
podcast yeah
yeah and I'm putting him over and he's
over here [__] trying to come at me
are you kidding me right yeah go ahead
dbag talk a little [__] the answer is
yes what were you going to say what were
you going to say dbag what kind of what
kind of [__] were you going to fing
complimenting you dude right as if Taz
hasn't accomplished his
life yeah nice oh I does a camera pick
up what just happened in there he looked
into the mic he went and just walk away
I know bro this is unprofessional I I
got to be honest with you you're talking
about t a guy who reached the Pinnacle
of one industry and then decided to jump
head first into another industry and has
become one of the most important people
in streaming media I would I my show I
proudly say uh uh
Trends worldwide yesterday for the whole
2our broadcast Jimmy Norton trended for
the hashtag the show Trends worldwide
I'm not bragging should but this guy dag
should [__] realize who he's dealing
with now I was trending I was no I was
going to say time we're not out of time
yes we are I just noticed we're like
really late Travis I Thought You end at
11:00 what kind of [__] show is this we
got at 52 commercials you got to tell me
where's your producer in there Lolly
gaging talking [__] he's got [__]
Derek nuring on the head of his [__]
like a baby lamb
show show we we the computer Cuts us off
t.com Taz show.com yes Taz show.com go
go watch or listen to the show and you
can you can watch Taz live or you can
watch it uh whenever you want Tok thanks
for hanging out to us come back and see
us again man I appreciate had a lot of
fun with you guys even dag and we'll see
you tomorrow